I'm
so
excited oh nice I got to tell you the
crowd is great today and uh thank you
for having me on the show really app the
exact opposite I feel like I'm freaking
out to meet you people are nuts when it
comes to you like when did you know that
you are so gosh darn it's daytime I
really want to say something else funny
uh how do I know I was funny I was a shy
kid I was never the class clown I
actually despised the class clown I
didn't I didn't really like the class
clown I was like sit down relax and uh
and and and let me go up and and do this
uh but as a young kid I I I love making
my family laugh okay so your family was
your
audience and you like but you did all
these other jobs like you worked as a
telemarketer worked at Olen Mills
portrait studio selling portrait
packages over the phone now with this
voice it's hard for you to do sales
because it looks like or it sounds like
I'm calling to collect
money like give us like a to sell me I
would change my voice to hi my name is
Sebastian Maniscalco I'm selling 8 by10
portrait packages today I was wondering
if your family was in need of a portrait
package and it would be very kind of
like proper not like you know some
Street Thug now can you give me the real
Sebastian selling portraits you want to
buy a
package um so yeah all these odd jobs I
worked at fod rockers I did you ever did
you ever spit in someone's
no I never sabotaged anybody I was I was
glazing I was glazing hamst no tell me
about glazing hamst because I'm
salivating yeah so I was I was glazing
hams at uh honey baked ham and I did you
ever like take
bites there's a theme here did you ever
spit did you ever steal I wouldn't have
been able to resist every once in a
while if you need to know I took a piece
of meat in the back ate it and then came
back out okay okay
[Music]
guys
you